la révolte dans les rues de tibilissi
pour une quatrième journée consécutive
la colère gronde devant le Parlement de
la Géorgie
et ce soir des scènes violentes et des
affrontements avec les policiers comme
on en a rarement vu dans cette jeune
démocratie
parce que mon pays doit faire partie de
l'Europe mais mon gouvernement ne le
comprend pas dice manifestants
au cœur du débat une loi des plus
controversée qui vient d'être adopté en
première lecture et qui a même entraîné
des batailles à coup de poing chez les
députés une loi dite inspirée de la
Russie qui obligerait tous les médias et
les ONG en Géorgie à se déclarer agent
étrangers si plus de 20% de leur
financement proviennent de l'extérieur
du pays
minimaloriste il s'agit d'une exigence
standard minimale de transparence et de
responsabilité disait le Premier
ministre garibashville la semaine
dernière mais dans un contexte de
rapprochement sans précédent avec la
Russie l'opposition l'accuse de dérive
autoritaire de saboter l'avenir du pays
et ses relations avec l'Europe et
l'Amérique
[Musique]
et nous ne voulons pas faire partie de
l'ex Union Soviétique nous sommes
tournés vers l'Occident de cet homme
de New York où elle est en visite
officielle devant la statue de la
liberté que la présidente de la Géorgie
a tenu à offrir son soutien aux
manifestant et a pris une fois de plus
ses distances du gouvernement
elle promet d'opposer son veto pour
stopper la loi mais cela risque d'être
en vain et déjà ce soir Washington parle
d'un recul démocratique pour le peuple
Géorgie
d'une loi qui s'y adoptée nuira la
capacité des États-Unis à continuer
d'être un partenaire pour la Géorgie ici
Tamara Alteresco Radio-Canada Montréal